thanks for joining us here at 11 i'm
denise valdez a lot of nevadans still
have the chance to get their shot
but for some time ran out too soon 8
news now reporter sasha loftis joins us
live from umc with tonight's story
denise hospital hospitals like this are
becoming overwhelmed again as covet 19
cases surged
here locally the woman i spoke with
tonight lost her husband to the virus
this week
she's now fulfilling one of his last
wishes to share his story
to help keep others safe this is the
longest i've ever been away from him
julie mikeworth is grieving the loss of
her husband
partner and best friend he was
the most loyal person
the most honest person the two were
married for 35 years
before kovitt 19 stole bob's life in a
matter of weeks
julie says bob was in his 70's and
considered high risk
but he was fully vaccinated still the
virus found him
and changed everything i don't think
people realize
what that feeling is that
you're you're helpless what the mike
worths went through
is heartbreaking but it's also rare
according to a recent nevada hospital
association report
95 percent of those hospitalized here in
our state
have not been immunized that's why julie
says bob
wanted his story to help others
understand
anything can happen he wanted me to
let people know you can't let your guard
down
now as she learns to live without the
man she loved more than
anything her message is simple
wear a mask and if you're able get the
vaccine
so you don't ever have to experience
this same kind of suffering
you don't want to go through what i went
through
julie contracted kovid 19 around the
same time as bob she does have
underlying conditions but says
she attributes her mild symptoms and
quick recovery to the fact that she was
vaccinated
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now